مجلس الامن الدولي ولايه باعته حفظ السلام
في لبنان يونيفال لمده عام من دون
الاستجابه لطلب النوباني لضروره تقيد تلك
القوات بمرافقه الجيش اللبناني والتنسيق
معه كنداك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما هي خلفيات قرار مجلس الامن
بتنبيل مهمه اليونسفيلد وما هي خياره
بيروت للتعامل مع الواقع الذي يفرضه تمديد
مهمه اليونسفان بصيغته الحاليه وما
التاثيرات التي يمكن ان تترتب على هذا
القرار في ضوء التوتر على الحدود بين
لبنان واسرائيل
طبعا لبنان ساعه في الايام الماضيه من اجل
تغيير بعض نصوص قرار مجلس الامن والتاكيد
على ضروره التنسيق بين القوات الطوارئ
الدوليه والجيش اللبناني قبل القيام باي
مهمه او تجديد
ولايه اليونال يساعد على حفظ السلام بين
البلدين وتسليط الضوء على هذه القضايا
التجديد في هذه المرحله الدقيقه يكتسي
اهميه اكبر من الصبر يبدو ان هناك ضغوط
امريكيه واسرائيليه وحتى للاسف بعض الدول
العربيه من اجل عدم تغيير قرار مجلس الامن
السابق او عدم ادخال اي تعديل عليه مما
ادى الى امتناع الصين وروسيا عن التصويت
وتحفظ لبنان قلق حقيقي
ازاءه نشاطات حزب الله على طول الحدود مع
اسرائيل والتي كانت واضحه للعيان تماما
كما ان هناك قلق ازاءه ما تريد الوقت
المتحده ما تريده بانه يجب ان لا يكون
هناك اخطار لسلطات اللبنانيه وهناك ايضا
بواعظ قلق حول
التوتر بين حزب الله والجيش اللبناني
ليس هناك خيار الى التعامل مع قوات طوارئ
الدوليه وانا برايي نحن بحاجه الى مزيد من
التنسيق والتعاون بين الجيش اللبناني
وقوات طوارئ في هذه المرحله الدقيقه كما
قال الامين العام لحزب الله حسن نصر الله
قبل قبل ايام هذا حبر على ورق في نهايه
المطاف مع ما يهم هو ان
القوى القوى الواقعه على الارض هي التي
تقرر كيف تتحرك
وهناك قلق من ان الايرانيين
يحسون ويشجعون حزب الله على نصب هذه الخيم
في قريه الغجر وما حدث في تلك القريه اثار
الانتباه حول هذا الموضوع
تحتدم المواجهات في الداخل الفلسطيني نرى
ان هناك تحركا من جنوب لبنان باتجاه
الشمالي
شمال اسرائيل وهذا ينعكس على ايضا قدره
الدوله اللبنانيه على التعامل مع هذا
الواقع في ظل هذا الانهيار المتمادي
اقتصاديا
صحيح انا يعني على الاقل خلال سنوات
الماضيه ساهمت قوات طوارئ الدوليه بتخفيف
التوتر الذي يحصل خصوصا عندما قيام القوات
الاسرائيليه باعتداءات على الاراضي
اللبنانيه اليوم تضاعفت
تضاعفت اهميه هذه القوه نتيجه ارتفاع
التوتر على الحدود الجنوبيه وحصول بضعه
مناوشات لها علاقه بالفصائل الفلسطينيه
ونشاطها المستجد في الجنوب اللبناني وكان
هناك ايضا قلق من جانب اسرائيل عبرت عنه
الولايات المتحده حول ما كان يتم في مناطق
الحدود حزب الله طبعا موجود في جنوب لبنان
هناك توتراته مع اسرائيل التي ليست هي
جديده بحد ذاتها لكن لنرى اي حال تنازلي
ممكن ان يتم التوصل رغم التوترات الخاصه
هناك مص امريكيه وحتى مصلحه ايرانيه
بالحفاظ على الاستقرار طبعا اسرائيل هي
التي تحاول توفير الاجواء اولا من خلال ضم
قريه الغجر ثانيا من خلال اقامه بعض
المنشات في مناطق اللبنانيه مثل تلاك
فرشوبه طبعا لبنان تحول خلال السنوات
الماضيه الى صندوق رسائل ان هناك قابليه
اكثر لحصول نزاع وتوترات على على الحدود
الجنوبيه مما كان عليه الامر قبل مثلا
ثلاث سنوات او اربع سنوات